From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is Emilye Crosby with Mrs. Peggy Jean Connor and we're at the McCain Library and Archives at the University of Southern Mississippi.
It's November 30th, 2015 and we're doing this interview as part of the Civil Rights History Project,
which is co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the National Smithsonian Museum for African American History and Culture.
Thank you so much. This is kind of...
I'm also here with John Bishop and Guha Shankar. Could you start by telling me about your family and when you were born and about growing up here in Hattiesburg?
I was born in Hattiesburg, Mississippi.
Then...
Well, my daddy, he always wanted a doctor for the (he always wanted) a doctor for the birth.
And when he came, when the doctors would come, they delivered all four of us, all four of us, three siblings and a doctor, Charles Smith.
My mother was quiet. I think I was in one tank.
And very shy when I was in school and made good grades, but I never volunteered to ask for nothing.
And I had a teacher, Ruby M. Tatum.
I learned later that it was Ruby M. Tatum.
She taught me seven grades. The first semester was citizenship.
And then that cheap, really put a lot of emphasis on Ridditch's student to vote.
That was something in that day.
And the second semester we had litter too.
But I remember her telling us, when you get 21 years old, you go to the courthouse, to the circuit clerk's office and Ridditch to the vote.
And so, that stuck with me, you know, and I started trying to register early.
It took me about 10 years to become registered.
Did you try the first time when you were 21?
I did. And the other thing you had to pay poll tax, two years.
I mean, yeah, for two years, two dollars.
Poll tax. And I would pay poll tax. And I would collect poll tax in my beauty shop for patrons that wanted, and it was afraid to go themselves.
Now, you pay poll tax during the time between January and April, like you paid your taxes before you have to pay penalties on your taxes.
So, I would take a list of them and just do me all the good in the world.
When I get there, I was standing, people behind me had the way to, I turned all those, no names, and had receipts for everyone.
And I just love that.
So, was this before or after you were in the movie?
This was before. And after even the movie.
Well, I'd like to tell how I got in the movie.
I don't want to rush you ahead, but when you were collecting poll taxes, did a lot of black business owners do that?
No.
Who else did you know besides you?
I didn't know nobody.
And I just told my customers.
No. I didn't get the idea to do that.
Well, I'd been talking and telling them I was going to pay my poll tax because you had to pay two conservative years.
And if you miss a year, you had to start all over again.
And I would tell them, you know, and I talked to them and they would tell some people and get a list and take a day.
They must have been unhappy to see you coming.
I didn't go every day, but they knew me.
So, who, you said that's a circuit plate?
Which office was that?
That was the voter registration officer.
So it was like Mr. Theron Lynd, it was the office where he was?
It's the same office.
Did they ever try to intimidate you?
No, nobody.
Nobody really bothered me.
I guess I looked like a little girl, you know, and they never looked at me.
They didn't realize how much trouble you could...
I didn't know how much trouble I could.
What did your parents do for a living?
Well, my mother, at that time, she was just a housewife and took care of kids.
And my daddy worked at a lumber yard.
He taught him lumber yard and then he got kind of elevated and he got...
He went to the cricket pit house and drive the owner to town and out on the coast of wherever he was going.
So he was like a show-off.
Was that a good job?
Well, it was okay when paying a whole lot.
I don't think he made much more than he was making when he was working in the lumber yard.
And then he would get up early, go to bed early, and then get up like about two o'clock and go wash your windows all downtown.
Yeah, I'm all just about all the business downtown he washed your windows.
So he made a living, you might say.
But after I got larger, well, I started my aunt had a beauty shop.
And in fact, she gave me her beauty shop when she left Hattiesburg.
That's how I become owner of my shop.
She...
I was the extra brick, brick, brick, brick, and I'm a fly home.
Because I didn't consider myself that.
I was just doing my part.
I thought my sister told me once that she said,
I wanted to go to all-con.
And I asked Daddy, could I go with the group that was going from Hattiesburg,
And he told me, asking, and that's when both of us come to Hattisbury.
So I helped take care of my siblings.
So your father was recognizing your contribution and I know that he had to be okay with you?
Was that usual at the time?
I didn't know nothing about.
He would tell them.
Like I said, it's been...
I know that she told me that.
I didn't know he had told me.
How many were you when you started working at your aunt's?
11.
And I got 10 cents a shampoo.
I was a shampoo girl.
I got 10 cents if I ever shampooed.
And she was a tough sister.
She would make me think what the lady had on and what she talked about.
I had to tell her, well she would give me a ticket.
And she write a name on it and I give it back to her.
She had to take it.
She gave it to me.
But I didn't say a word.
I just go on and do it.
And so she gave me the beauty school.
She had a beauty school.
And I graduated from beauty school in 1946.
It was her school?
Her school.
So she had the shop at the school?
She didn't charge you for going to the school.
So I guess even though she was tough on you.
She recognized your contribution.
I guess so.
How did you feel about your work when you were 11?
Did you enjoy it?
I enjoyed it.
I didn't get a chance to go to a lot of school flunk.
She didn't because I was working.
But it didn't bother me.
And then I was going to post for talking.
Yes.
But she was married to a minister.
And she was kind of, I think, heading her mind.
She was going to be one day.
I said, so it wasn't too much gossiping went on.
She had a lot of the magazines and things.
And she had to read and run too much gossiping.
Did she really, because that's how there were many women
that were ministers?
No.
But she would, missionaries, they would...
That idea.
Well, you just told me she was married to a minister.
What kind of work did he do?
Carpenter.
He was a carpenter.
And he decided with some of his members,
he was from a place called Farm Habermy, Mississippi.
I from Canton, Mississippi.
And they were holding this people.
And my grandmother was of the Church of God.
And my mother's mother.
And he met my aunt who was in Houston, Texas.
And they got married.
They moved back to Mississippi.
Is that your mother's sister?
My mother's sister.
My mother's brother on the beauty school,
Franklin Beauty School, in that day.
So it's really a family business in some ways?
Yes.
It's a lot of beauticians.
And I remember.
I had a picture at home.
It was taken in the 70s.
And all sitting at the table.
And I said, a family of beauticians.
Was everybody kin to you?
Yeah, everybody.
It was family.
So did, was it different shops?
Were they like Hattiesburg?
Oh no, he had it.
It was all over Texas in the latter.
We thought he was rich.
He walked, we found him and he died.
So did you ever think about doing any other line of work
or did it just seem natural to follow your aunt?
It just seemed natural.
Because if you'd work in the home,
she wouldn't make it in her money.
A lot of people were making $2 a day.
And then when I worked in the shop,
I wouldn't like people that stayed at home
and they didn't get the, I got the Fah price.
She told me you've been that athletic.
So I was getting the same thing she was getting.
Even when you were younger?
So did she let you set your own price while you were like
when you started doing your own?
No.
Okay.
So whoever came in the shop, they picked what was on the earth.
What were your pounds like?
My daddy was a strict man.
And we walked the line.
I tell you that, three girls.
And he was going to make a bow out of that one,
one, one, uh, son he had.
So he had to mow yard.
You know, and we would get out there and hit him.
So he tried to be, this is what the boys do
and this is what the girls do.
Just mix it up.
You did say that you three girls spoiled your baby brother.
That's right.
It's more than right.
You enjoyed that?
Yeah, I really did.
Enjoy it.
Did your mother ever work out as high as the house?
She did.
My daddy took seat.
And she did work some out of the house
when he got sick.
And she worked for people and they didn't have no more than we had.
And when she gets to working,
I don't have any money.
Do you want this radio?
You want this?
You want, you know, and that was her way of paying.
And we were glad to get to read here.
This is white families?
Yeah, white families.
What did your parents teach you?
You mentioned that teacher who taught...
I'm trying to think I didn't know Mississippi allowed the black schools to teach citizenship.
We had it.
And a young lady that was ahead of me,
days away, she died back not too long ago.
She don't even remember having citizenship when she was a great head of me.
But we had citizenship.
Do you know if your teacher was registered?
She was.
That's one thing she did not tell us.
She wasn't.
Did she try, do you know?
I got registered.
I went to her.
She had retired, then,
and asked her about going,
she said, oh, I'm not going through the book there.
Did you remind her?
I told her.
She said, well, I did do something good, didn't I?
She was a good teacher.
She.
In literature too.
Did she say why she wasn't done?
I knew who I, you know.
Was this in the early days?
This was, you know, well,
see, I didn't get registered until...
I want to say...
I want to say it was in 1770.
I'm not sure, but it was way out there.
I think it's been time for...
Was it after the voting right act?
The voting right act came in 65-
25-
65-
ucci.
Was it due to the Clinton later to register, you know,
you know, people.
Some peoples that they had names, you know?
And I
I never got a car all I got it's head up to the letter.
And was that because of the court?
Yeah, because the court was all here.
Okay.
So your father was one of the people?
In 64, get my father, my daddy, he was something else in the movie.
And I'll let him.
Not to tell me what to do.
Uh-huh.
I got registered.
And I come to that in January, 12 days before Freedom Day.
Okay.
So that was in 64?
Yeah, it was in 64, just guess what?
That's when I got registered.
And I, but I never got a car.
I didn't know how it worked.
So did they, when you, when you passed the test, did most people get a car?
You get a car.
Well, was that for the poll tax?
Oh no, you get a receipt for your poll tax.
And you get a car for registered.
Does it say like what your district is and everything?
And no, it is.
Just that you passed it.
Uh-huh.
And because when we went to the primary meeting in 64, uh-uh, we, it was 18 of us went
to the library precinct.
And it was downtown where the culture center is now, on Main Street.
When we walked in, it was 18.
My mom and my dad, it was with me.
And I had been teaching citizenship classes too.
And I had some of my, uh, members in the citizenship class.
But it was a total of 18.
And when we walked in there, see, they have just
been doing things by a sham and all, you know, this right down.
Because they've always been Republicans.
But they went in the name of Democrats.
But they always voted, a stated home, voted for the Republican.
So, uh, that was my library meeting.
That's right.
And this, the curry was the chairman of the, of the county thing.
I don't know.
He was a lawyer also a lawyer here.
So, was that the white maiden that you went to?
I went to white.
No, no, no.
So, you took 18 people to the white maiden?
That's right.
We didn't call out into the mess in summer.
That's true.
When we got to this, we went to the white people's meeting.
You took 18 people?
We had 18 people.
And I think it was about three on the end.
They missed the curry and in two more men.
Oh, as that, as I can't exactly.
But it was three.
And they will, they just didn't know what they're saying.
They wanted to run.
But they, and so they call.
Thereland.
This was in the public library.
So, they had telephone there.
People didn't have, you didn't have sales on the other thing.
So, they called Thereland and told them the situation.
And, is supposed to start at 18.
About 1030, they got a good number to come.
He was calling everybody they could call,
right around town.
And a lot of them should be involved in the library
precinct.
But, so they didn't know who it was.
I was the only one that was registered.
And he, they called and he took the names,
called them down there to Thereland.
And Thereland asked where that Peggy, comma, she's
the only one can participate in the.
Was that a real rule?
Or did they just make that up at the time?
What?
That you had to be a registered voter to participate
in the Democratic primary and that was a, that was a,
that was a, that was one of the ones in the,
they weren't one, they made up.
How did you feel going into that?
Just, my chest, I don't know it all.
And I felt good.
So, by me being the only one that attended,
the prime could participate with the primary convention.
I, I guess, just for P.S.A.K. or whatever,
they voted me to go to the county.
So they did in 64.
In 64.
So I know that I mean, I'm, and then when you have
the elections, you, with account ballots, you know,
paper ballots.
And after the poll calls, I'd be the only one there
to help count the ballots.
And then when you have to go to the courthouse
to certify the ballots, that was only one.
And I got, when they had the county meeting,
I was voted to go to the district.
And that's, that's still in the white Democratic party,
the right, the right, the, this is the regular Democrats.
They took me through that.
When, when you were talking about certifying,
watching the, the account, is that for the regular elections,
or is that for the party?
That's for the regular elections.
Regular elections.
So, I want to.
And, and a lot of them, I could outcount them, you know,
and boy, it was, but I didn't get elected to go to the state.
And this is in 64.
No, this was in 64.
OK, this is in 68.
68.
OK.
So, and when you went to the library meeting with the 18
people, the library district, I'm sorry, the library
precinct was that 64 or 68?
That was six.
That was 64, because after they turned, a lot of people
all over, they turned them away.
We say we are a name out, get our own party.
And we also named it Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party.
That was in 64.
And then the one where you got elected to the district,
that was in 68?
68.
OK.
I was a Freedom Democrat.
And a regular Democratic Party, you said.
And, yeah, maybe we can come back to those.
You said that your father, well, you know,
I'm not, not everybody could get their parents to get involved.
Well, we were small.
My dad belonged to the NAACP,
And he also belonged with the mean and 100 as something.
But it was all political.
The governor's thought that 100, the ones that was that
after the Brown decision, there was a Brown decision
after the Brown, who was Brown decision.
I think, and he tried to see if he could get them to go along
with segregation, if they have more resources for the schools.
Or is it something different?
I don't remember.
But I know, my dad, it was Secretary of both of the organizations.
That's the end of the AC.
And we used to have to write letters where they're going to meet.
And they've made them to the post office in Oregon.
So you were writing letters?
Yeah, I was.
Real young.
And Joyce would help too.
So we come up.
My daddy, we talk about it, man.
We'd be sitting around at the dining room table, eating,
and dad had reading the paper too.
We come up with him in the paper too.
Is that part of that strict?
Yes.
Which page is that?
He was the Hattiesburg American.
And he finally got a job working for the Hattiesburg American.
Well, you were the Hattiesburg American.
He was a porter, they called him.
But he helped get the press set and all that.
And he learned a lot of working it up there.
Did he talk to you about the end of the ACP?
And why he belonged to a ten-tony-year?
No, he didn't.
He never did.
Because he found out that a lot of the NAACP, where I
won't say a lot.
Some of them were going telling the whites what they
were discussing at the meetings.
He just entrusted.
Do you worry about that?
Yeah, he did and that, and he got mad about that.
Do you remember how old you were when this was happening?
Well, I was still in school.
Do you still remember?
That was for four.
Because I graduated in 50.
So that was going on before.
Before Emmett Teele and all that.
Was he registered to vote?
At one time, and it took him out the wrong.
He and my mother vote for registered voters.
Were you ever involved in the NAACP?
They didn't have at that time.
Nothing, Dad.
So do you think your parents had a tune about registering
to vote in the NAACP?
Do you think that influenced you?
They did a whole lot of it.
And I know one another thing.
If I had stayed married, I couldn't have been at that.
He went, he went in the head.
And she, you want to tell us about your marriage and the end
of your marriage?
Well, he was a, what they call it now.
He's brutally, you know, he loved to fight.
And he was an alcoholic too.
And I didn't know that when I first married him.
Because we were in school together.
But he went to the Korean War.
He joined Stop School with the Korean War.
And he was a different person when he come back.
This was all before married.
We got married when he came back.
Would you still follow the women's approach?
And he would be coming up?
And so you married him?
And did you all stay in Hattiesburg?
Well, he was stationed in Greenville, South Carolina.
We stayed up there while.
That's when I really found him out.
And my son was born.
And so I talked to him in the living, me bring a baby home.
And then he didn't go back.
And then he kept calling and talking.
I did go back.
And that's when La Joa's come along.
Back behind each other.
And so I just could take it along.
And when he came out of service and come here,
and his mother lived in Gulfport.
And he started busing one night.
This could all be anything.
He started busing one night.
My dad had told him he couldn't do that in his house.
He was cussing and going on too.
And so he called his mom and she come down.
And that was the last of his family to stay in.
She came.
I don't know where he went to call, because we didn't have
a telephone at that time.
And he did go call her.
And she came after.
And she was knocking on the window.
And she said, come on baby, mama come, got you.
Come to get you.
And we all live at.
And he went on down there.
But we never went back together.
I would, huh.
Was it how it turned into marriage?
No, it wasn't really.
My dad had tried to talk me out of it.
You see, every family needs a man.
Get them a mother of 10, I said, no, he had all the chances
to get like, you can be the man for a while.
My dad is, and they call him daddy.
That's what they call him.
They didn't hall the room in.
He got us, we got it the fullest.
And he got married again.
He had about six children.
My second daughter had polio.
It was him.
She was two years old.
She took polio.
It was kind of an epidemic around here.
A lot of people's children, dad.
But she did kind of come around because she couldn't,
she was in iron lung.
We got where she could stay out some while.
And she had to go back.
And that happened about two years.
And one night, she was at home.
And I had the best pediatrician, the fact that, oh,
that was Dr. Temple.
He, I could call him any time at night.
And he answered the phone.
He's writing the answer phone.
He answered the phone.
And he told me, he said, this tank.
He said, well, Jean, they're right.
I call him Jean.
He said, Jean, that's a long trip over there.
He had to take all the way to Big Spring, Texas.
Jackson didn't have iron lung at that time.
And so it was the Catholic hospital over there.
I think it was emergency.
But anyway, we would take her over there.
And on our way, he would call the highway patrol.
And notify every time he's coming through,
that we would come through with a varic seat baby.
This time, he said, you know
they got a iron lung and Laura.
And I said, you want to go there?
I said, we'll be closer to home.
So we went up there.
We took her in the car.
Had been getting the ambulance to take.
It wasn't.
It's the same thing they used for.
But they did.
And so we got up there.
They had a iron lung and didn't know about it up there.
No how to work it.
That's right.
I had to show them how to work it.
But she had a dangerism to births in her head.
That's what she just had seizures until she died.
How old was she?
She was small.
She was a smart little sister and then.
When I got bumped into it, after she got sick.
And her brother slept in the bottom and her cheese
was at the top.
She wasn't going nowhere.
Of course, she was paralyzed.
So young Dr. Malone was on.
Went to television in the house and somebody
bought her a television.
So he had to go in her room.
And she was laying there watching television.
She's happy.
She's laying on this side on the left.
She could kind of feed herself.
But anyway, she got the wiggling.
So what's the matter?
Get out of here.
I see this woman having a baby.
Oh, man.
She was something of smart.
She could read.
So you had a really hard time with her in your early family.
It all happened.
Was her father around at all?
He didn't come to see her a whole time.
She was sick.
But he came to the funeral and cried and like a baby.
He said, gee, you know what happened to me?
I said, no.
When I got worried about that baby's head die,
so I took one of his children by another woman.
And I put him on the block in the choc his ear at all.
Yeah, that's what he told me.
Didn't you have any response for that?
Yeah.
How did you respond?
I don't remember saying nothing.
I don't remember.
But anyway, he just lost it, I guess.
Were you living with your parents then?
No, just a little bit.
When he left, that's when I started staying with my parents.
And like I say, my children all call my daddy.
Daddy.
They grew up with a good father, baby.
He hadn't been that way.
He did.
He didn't pay no child support and all that.
And I was this as big aty to the Zachadie.
I said, well, if you ain't gonna pay it, I'm not gonna make it.
So I was doing pretty good in the view shot then too.
I guess if you had tried to make it, you'd have to talk to him.
If you were trying to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So is this in the 50's then?
Yes.
She died.
Let's see if she was born in 50.
Oh.
She died in 50's.
It's a little jealous.
You said 53 when we were looking at it.
I don't know how it is back to right?
It's 53 at the time.
Because they were real close, real close.
Well, they could talk good.
They were brother and her.
They would sit down in whole conversation.
You know what they were saying?
And she died in 50 now.
Thank you.
Were you running the shop then?
Did you have your hand given you the shop at that time?
Yeah.
So you were running the shop and taking care of you?
How did you get involved in the movie?
The co-pho office was across the street from my beauty shop.
You know, I should have showed you that when you would come in up Mobile Street.
You want to show us how it's going back?
Yeah, it's a park there.
That's where the copo house was.
It called a car and just burned up.
It was a brick building.
Was that in the movement?
Was it burnt down?
No.
This was after.
Because I remember Dr. Tussle went down there and got some bricks.
And he was in the archive.
So you were saying that the co-pho office was across from your beauty shop?
Yes.
It was five, seven, and a half.
This lady had a down-institutory building.
And she gave that to co-pho to use.
She didn't charge no rent or nothing.
She was in this woods.
And she lived upstairs.
And all antique furniture and stuff was up there.
It was real nice.
And it kind of took care of the young men and the people.
She sent them away.
But in my shop was kind of daggers like across from there.
And I was standing in the door of the beauty shop.
And I had been seeing a lot of commotion going on over there.
I didn't know how I was going to find out who it was going on.
Because I wasn't the type to walk over there and ask for, you know.
And Giaw came across.
And he was telling me about this as the co-pho office.
He was SNCC-fellows.
They had mass meetings done in Parmas.
And he said, it's one tonight.
That's OK.
And so he said, why don't you come down?
So I talked to a friend of a girl, a man.
She had a car.
And we went down.
And who the Fannie Lou Hamer was the speaker that night?
You didn't have a chance.
That woman sent me on fire.
And she said, oh, she just, I don't know.
So after that, Victoria Gray Adams asked me about going to the workshop.
I'm non-violence.
And that's where I...
Dorothy F. Cotton, Andrew Young, would teach us that.
Is that in Dorchester Center?
Dorchester Center.
Right on the line of South Carolina and Georgia there.
And that reminded me.
But anyway, they're whole week.
It was really good.
And I left the island.
I know.
The all of us that were there, we were supposed to go home
and start citizenship classes where we could, if you can't,
get an ambulance somewhere, have it at your house.
So I came back and rubbed and ridged you in.
Passed a true light church.
I went to him and asked him about having citizenship classes.
And he told me he said, sure.
He said, I would, after proud meeting on Wednesday nights.
And he said, who ever stayed.
And I had about two many in my class.
I think people came from Hattiesburg to the workshop in Dorchester Center.
Well, when I went, it was just...
It was Helen Anderson, Ruth Campbell.
You know, it was just three of us.
Did other people go other times?
And JW Brown went, I know.
That's all I can remember.
He had gone before I went.
Did the people that came to your class, did they go try and register?
Yes, they did.
Was anybody able to do it right away?
No.
They were in the number that was ordered by a court.
They were, certainly, in part of the court.
But see, when I got the letter, he didn't tell me that the court had ordered me.
He said, he was.
And I thought, well, that's some special.
Did you think he had converted?
He could lend a bunch of things.
He said, no, he didn't do it.
He called me in love with you.
He told you that recently.
Yes, he did.
Yes, she passed out some papers that I got registered in June.
I said, no, this is not right.
I said, I was registered before Freedom Day in January.
She said, but he wrote me and said, I was registered in June.
But the court, she said, well, she said, well, the court ordered him.
He wasn't doing it another day.
So what did you think of G.I.?
Oh, G.I. didn't want to threaten nobody.
He was a good leader.
He really was.
What made him a good leader?
He listened.
He really listened.
And then he could tell you why you think this and why you think this.
He was really good.
He didn't step back from nothing.
I remember we marched to the courthouse one night.
And this is before we started there.
We started there.
We started F.D.P.
And all of a sudden he attacked.
He watched him for the Korean war.
It was called Vietnam War.
Vietnam War.
And it was unconstitution.
A lot of people didn't like that.
In the community?
Yeah, they didn't want him talking about the war.
Did they disagree with them?
Disagree.
So he was doing that at a mass meeting?
No, this was on the march.
On the march.
On the steps of bar scionic collapse.
So were they just worried about him talking in public?
Yes, that's what it was.
Like I say, it was always somebody that went and told people what was going on in.
And they were supposed to keep it down.
Did you know who was doing that?
Found out.
One day they did.
What did they do when he found out?
He told the guy.
He was a friend of that.
I would not go call that name.
But he was also very happy with the NAACP.
And NAAC was one piece.
So I know you started trying to register the vote when you got 21.
Did you join NAACP?
Yes.
And I took.
I mean, I have a reason for doing something.
I tell people I joined NAACP for insurance.
Because I had that son coming up in my brother and me.
But the first thing they asked you when you go for help.
Are you a member of the NAACP?
You mentioned your son and your brother.
Were you worried about them?
Yes.
Well, my dad had a shoe shine, Paula, in front of my beauty shop.
My beauty shop was at the back of it.
In the police with Pick-A-L, you know.
And my son.
And once in the morning, they were up there.
The shiny shoes put full time for insurance.
Me and come back and get the shoes shining.
And the police come up there and harass them and all.
And the shiny shoes sound into them.
I don't remember.
But they took Johnny and arrested.
And my son ran all the way out.
He was out of breath.
He and the dog.
We had a dog named Spot.
And he stayed in that shop a lot of times at night.
And he was gone with Danny.
And so when we went to court,
the two policemen couldn't tell the same story.
One told one thing happened.
The other one told him.
And the judge told my daddy.
He said, I can't say this is police court.
He said, I cannot find nothing
and police got to be your son.
And he said, I think daddy had to pay $150 or something.
Just a little son.
That's a lot of money going on.
And he told daddy, not told my daddy,
and get him away from here.
So he left here.
He was the judge trying to be helpful.
At least we think he was.
And he said, I can't let him go.
I have to charge him something.
And so my sister was living in California at that time.
And some other family was here.
And I can't remember what that was.
But anyway, the Johnny got in the truck of that car.
And that's how he left Hattiesburg, until he crossed Mississippi River
of Louisiana between, you know, near Louisiana.
And he stayed.
He didn't come back until in the seventh.
So you wanted to make sure you had that NAACP card
in case you needed some backup.
That's right.
And that was before you got in the movie.
Did you aware of Clyde Kennard trying to go to Southern?
Yes.
Did you follow that?
I follow.
He would be on Mobile Street up there at Fats Kitchen.
That's where he would stop and get some coffee.
And he's an humble guy.
The humble is he could be.
I really don't think he thought that was going to happen to him.
He thought he was just reasonable.
He was determined.
Did you ever go to any of the court for them?
No one they were trying.
I didn't call him.
Did you ever know when mega-ever's was coming through?
Did you ever meet with him?
No, I never did.
I don't know.
He came here.
I don't remember.
He would come to Palmers, down his seat and say, John.
I don't know if he would go to the church, but in the 50s he would come through trying to organize.
I don't know if he would mass media dreams.
So what I did?
I thought you'd come into that mass media.
She was there just as proud that she could be in a starch and iron dress.
She was calling her the nervous and nervous.
She'd tell her, no.
I'm not going to.
She could sit there, nervous and nervous.
Did you?
What did she think that night?
Go tell it on the mountain.
So this was the day in 63 then because it was the 4th freedom day?
Yes.
It was 4th freedom day.
This must have been like after they had gone to Washington.
Oh, after the March on Washington.
This was after that.
It must have been like September because I'm thinking it was full Christmas that I went to the church.
So you were pretty quickly went to Dorchester Center and you were teaching the citizenship class.
Do you remember Jean Wheeler?
Jean Wheeler?
She stayed at the school.
Yes, I know Jean.
Tell me what she was like.
With a little shout skirt.
Oh boy, she could wear those shorts.
Yes, I remember her.
You remember she organized in the MFEP?
Yes.
And then she soon moved away.
I don't know everywhere she went but I know in the summer of 64 she was in Philadelphia.
That's probably what she was.
She said she wanted to make sure that the clan knew they weren't going to win in Philadelphia.
Was she a good organizer?
Yes, she was.
So how did you manage to keep up your beauty shop and your children?
I wanted that too and my daughter talked about it.
She said I never miss nothing when I went to school.
She said that?
I'd be in the shop and I would leave people in the shop.
They'd wait till I go to her programs and whatever and they'd be waiting until I come back.
She said she's...
Somebody would tell her, you know my man coming, she's working.
My mama will be here.
So she's standing in the street looking up.
So she said, here she come now.
I wanted to...
I don't know.
I did all I did.
Did you have health in the shop?
I worked by myself.
I didn't have...
I was all lonely beauty operator.
And I was having problems with the other beauticians and all, you know.
What kind of problems?
They would tell some of my clan tales that you go full-riding and you're going to get burned up in that shop with her.
They kill my business because they ain't mind waiting on me.
That's when I went to work at the hand back.
Because you lost so many customers?
I would still catch some when I come get off and work and all.
Were they afraid because of the movement?
Were they afraid that they were going to...
They must have been.
They did health.
Did your business come back after?
I wasn't going back.
I...
I lost my top.
Were you talking about your customers?
Yeah.
And one customer...
Her boss, her husband, was a clansman.
And she would tell me things, you know, about being...
When they were going up there to...
to fight up there at Oxford.
So when Meredith...
You say if I'd up at Oxford, was that when James Meredith was there?
Yes, right.
So she knew about the clan going up there?
Oh, yeah.
She knew all about...
They don't pay...
You know, they would talk in front of you...
as if you weren't there.
They didn't think you had since enough to tell me about it or nothing.
Because that's what I was telling one of the women that would go up there to the precincts.
Because we worked the precinct.
Because the...
Corporal workers would give us a thing saying that we were supposed to be there.
For what?
Yeah.
And they would just be talking and a lot of stuff.
They would just talk about it.
And one lady said, they don't...
They were talking all in front of us.
I said, honey, they don't count us.
They all they got to do is say, I didn't say it and you go, you don't catch it for the time.
Did that change when people were able to vote?
Did that attitude...
Did it change at all after voting?
No.
I worked a long time on the polls.
Heap on count the votes.
And...
I never...
Nobody never bothered me.
Never.
You would tell them you would...
I want to say I worked for nothing.
But they weren't getting the $3.
But they weren't paying anything.
Everyone's paying me nothing.
Were they working for the Democratic Party?
The Regulus?
Or was that working for the election?
For election.
Commission?
Yeah.
You know, I've often wondered about this.
They must have a election commission back then.
Because the people they worked for were the ones that counted the votes.
And certified and all that.
I don't really remember anything about election commission
to few years later and some Black Start campaign.
I don't really know how it worked.
But I know in Claiborne County there were white election commissioners
until after the voting rights act.
And then they got beat a couple of them.
So then there was an integrated group.
And then eventually I think half-CinAmerican one, four out of five.
But they didn't have it before.
But I'm not sure how it worked.
I think it was just on the book.
That could be.
That makes sense.
I don't really need it.
You were telling me before about how you got arrested.
And then you were going to get arrested?
Oh, yes.
We went up there.
We made a round around.
Not a round.
You've won't go any into the round by the jail.
Come up by the Masonic Temple and to the furniture store.
And the line was going around.
So in front of the courthouse kind of back and forth in front of the courthouse?
No.
We went all the way around.
So almost all the way around the building?
You couldn't, well no sidewalk next to the furniture store.
That's stricken and furniture I think it was.
So you had to turn.
But it's a line going and a line coming.
And then you got to get the inside of the computer.
So is this before Freedom Day?
Oh, no.
No.
I was after it.
After Freedom Day.
Okay.
But that's when the menaces came down.
And a lot of other workers and other states.
And we had a lot of people.
For Freedom Day?
And the worker came the night before.
Did you hear him?
You were there?
Right there.
And you know when you go in the church you would think some people would have summer of spring.
He'd have put his foot up on me.
I've heard some of the things he used to say.
He was terrible.
He was okay.
I like him.
Did you tell him to say did you enjoy it when you were in?
Did you hear him talking back to the officers?
Oh yeah.
What do you remember?
What else do you remember about Freedom Day?
Freedom Day.
It was Poin Down Ring.
And police didn't have no...
Rain gear.
One of the stores downtown gave them all rain coats.
And that's how they stayed out there all day in that rain.
But it was...
You just felt like you was free, you know?
And I was talking to one writer.
He said, why were you out there?
I was getting my freedom.
And Jerry Nash.
He thought that was the funnest thing.
Getting my freedom.
Did any of the people coming into town doing the ministers?
Did they stay with you or any of you?
Oh yeah.
It's a lot of people came to Rep. John Conyers Jr.
He stayed at my house.
And I was told after was...
FBI agents stayed.
I guess they wanted to make sure nothing happened to the congressman.
So it was fun.
And I didn't have to be a street skater.
And my dad would take shifts.
You know, he'd stay up.
My mother would go to bed early and he would get up and stay up at...
He had been paralyzed, but he started walking and he had a cane.
And the cane was the man across us.
And people put out that old man sitting there with a shotgun across his leg.
Probably got me a day, put that out.
Yeah.
That was the word.
He was sitting there with a shotgun.
Did you get threatened with people threatening you?
Nobody threatened me.
But after we come back from watching, from New Jersey,
and you know who we went up there to?
Atlantic City.
And Los Angeles.
And you asked if you were threatened.
Oh, I was going to tell you.
I'd never been on my airplane before my life.
And we were campaigning for...
Me and the main Johnson.
And I went to New York.
Johnny Cameron went to Philadelphia, I think it was.
And just different, one of the delegates, we went to other states campaigning for him.
My telephone bill, I had got a telephone about that time.
But anyway, they knew I had got on the phone, somebody.
I mean, they got on the plane and daddy asked us to phone.
And they told us that our telephone bill is due.
It didn't have to be paid back by the clock, or we couldn't get out.
It's one of the things my daddy just wouldn't pay to be here.
I don't think it was about $15.
Yeah.
And it wouldn't be the problem.
That was they were going to get you with that?
I guess, I don't know.
So I couldn't call back.
But I wasn't threatened.
And my daughter, when Felicia [Connor], when they desegregated [the] self-created [white] schools",
and she was six to integrate.
Yeah. Freedom of choice.
Did she want to do that?
She didn't know.
You know, back then, children did what you say to them.
And they didn't question.
And I said to myself, I had been out to California with my sister,
and what happened about that time?
So daddy told me I need to come home.
And I got home like two days before the registration would end.
And she was a little plump girl.
And she was just skipping all the way.
That's a lot of him.
She was a baby, don't know what I'm getting into.
And we went up to the old headless bird car.
It's burning.
It had a lot of...
You haven't got it fixed yet.
She went up there.
And I didn't even know that the school name.
I know it was on 7th Street, crossing Herkley.
It was the name Jefferson Davis Elementary School.
I did, but I had never paid no attention.
And so he said, what school...
What school you want to send that girl to?
I said, I don't know the name of it.
I said, but it's located across from Hercules."
He said, Jefferson Davis.
Are you ready to change my name?
Absolutely, okay.
She didn't know.
She just know she was changing school.
And she's talked to some of the white kids later.
After they graduated from high school and all.
They didn't know what was going on either.
After I come these strange children coming to my room late.
See, all the kids were in that classroom.
And then they take the children to...
They go to the black school first and then they carry them away?
No, no, no, no.
Parents had to bring them.
But they would hold those kids until all the white kids get in that class and that seat.
And then the teacher would walk on the end.
And then they would say, is that why they would do that?
I don't know.
Make sure there wasn't any fighting.
It wasn't nothing going on.
I tell you, he had his spirit.
Nothing happened.
So what did she think about going to the white school?
She didn't know.
Didn't pay her no attention.
She didn't know she was the only spot in there.
And the teacher said, she won't let you ignore.
She said, they might try something.
She will not let you.
She was in the air today.
She used the personality for it.
And she still that way.
So we started to talk about when you got arrested when you were picketing at the courthouse?
We picketing and they let us march around one time and come back.
And he said, I'm going to stop it right here.
You.
Marching mighty good, looking mighty good.
Good.
See how you can march back there to that house behind.
And he's talking about the jail.
The jail.
And I went in that jail, my own.
They tried to keep people with leadership away from the other people.
They moved me from the jail to the farm out there where they put people in work.
You know, to work to find.
It was in the city, though.
It's not far from where the police station is now.
You were a leader and you wanted to make sure you didn't organize everybody in jail.
Yes, I was out there.
It was quite a few.
I was out there.
They arrested 60 some people that morning.
And then some come that afternoon and they're ready to spend.
We ended up having about 100 people in there.
What was it like in jail?
We saw songs.
We told stories.
And the man was on one side and the well was on the other side.
And he put a dipper and water in the middle of the flow.
And that's how you drink your water.
And then you had to.
I don't even remember going to the bathroom that all.
I don't remember.
You were there a week right?
Yeah, it was that week.
I went.
I don't remember that.
They could.
Were you worried about your children when you were in jail?
No, I didn't worry about them.
I was going to tell them that.
What did your parents think about you being in the movie?
My mother.
She wasn't a said.
Nothing.
No way.
Because if John Henry was far, she's far too.
But we've been thinking, hill-aigling, you know.
She died in 86.
I don't think she ever attended Mass Meeting.
She stayed home.
And my children, they never attended Mass Meeting.
She would stay.
Just me and my dad.
But she came to the precinct meeting with you?
Oh, yes.
That's interesting.
But different thing.
Precinct man, he was meeting with us in the daytime.
So you think she didn't want to go out at night?
Now, would your dad pick it with you?
Oh, yes, he'd pick it.
Your only came.
So you were a team.
You told me before that when you went to March in front of the courthouse
that you knew you were going to get arrested?
Yes, when we left the COFO office office,
we all gave that the COFO office office.
We walked up Mobile Street, the Batson Street,
and see Batson Street, right in front of the...
it runs out in front of the courthouse.
We didn't get in the street.
We walked on the sidewalk all the way.
And then we just ran out and started.
How did you know you were going to get arrested?
Because they had told us if you come up here,
you go into jail.
The last group that was up there the day before.
So you come again, you go into jail.
And you weren't worried about that?
Nine o'clock, we were ready.
So they thought that was going to be enough to stop you?
Yeah.
That's what they thought.
How did you end up getting out?
Mr. and Mrs.
with the name.
Thought I'd never forget that.
But anyway, they put their house $1,000.
All those people got that money back.
So if we had given them cash money, we wouldn't have.
Did you have to go to court for that?
No, I'd law you some hand.
You have always wanted to.
Did they get it thrown out?
Yeah.
Can you tell me about organizing the FDP?
Yes.
When I was in Dorchester Center,
Dorothy told us that we were going to try to attend the primary meetings.
And then after we couldn't...
It's SNCC's some of the smartest people.
You know?
They knew all along that we were going to try that.
And so we went to the...
tried to go to primary meetings.
And we didn't have poll tax.
I was the only one that really paid the poll tax.
And they shouldn't even be asking that at a present meeting.
We didn't talk nothing about who was going to vote for all.
You know, nothing.
So I...
The end of that 18 didn't have a one vote and that was my vote.
So I don't know what they were doing for a piece of second.
But I was elected to go to the county meeting with the other group.
And then...
When we got to the district meeting,
it was hell at the cold house too.
I didn't get no vote.
So that's what I got.
But...
But you know, I would be the only flat in no field, no field at all.
You just weren't worried about it?
I'm worried at all.
I know the good law was taking care of me.
I just...
He had to be...
Because he was all kind of clans up in the...
Did you ever...
Were the clans ever out when you were watching?
Were they being town too?
Yeah, but they weren't dressed out as.
It was one guy that he was kind of...
I think he was kind of all...
He would come and try to know you, you know.
We didn't try to integrate nothing until the business...
Until...
That summer.
So summer 64 after the Civil War, after the court...
I mean after the Congress that already passed along.
Yeah, that's right.
He would go to the crisis and rule worth and...
You know, I went down to our drugstore.
I had a customer that had been cooking after like 20 or 30 years.
And she just kept after me.
Gee, why don't you come down to the store?
I said, okay.
So I made my mind up to go.
And my brother's wife was pregnant and very pregnant.
Did you bring your relationship?
She went with me and my brother had a fear.
Gee, you're gonna get my wife to you.
But anyway, we went in our drugstore and it was full.
We went to see...
So we decided we just...
You know, walk around.
They saw different stuff in there.
And I couldn't think of nothing to buy, the Dicks' Paper Road.
I looked up and saw Dicks' Paper Road.
And this was in July.
I bought a box and she said, she said,
they're like that.
But they knocked together.
I said, don't care.
So she hopped on one stool and I hopped on one.
But we weren't together, you know.
And all those men that was mostly me sitting around it,
they went running to the kitchen with the plates and the hand.
And then he come to the man that owned it out.
And he said, may I help you?
I said, do you have a menu?
He said, no, he said, we can't serve you here.
No, we cannot serve you here.
He said, but I'm sorry, but we can't.
I said, what's your name?
And he told me his name and I can't even think of it now.
But anyway, he said, I'm the owner.
And so we left.
And I filed suit.
Do you think he really was sorry?
I don't believe it.
He might have been.
But you know, if he had let us,
they would have got him.
I don't know.
What happened with your suit?
It went for about, oh, in courts.
Made about four years or so.
And he wrote me a letter.
He wrote me a letter.
No flood.
Down where I live, we have problems with flood.
And the river's not flat.
This is kind of state to a three-week.
I don't have them left.
So he wrote me a letter and asked me to come.
I haven't been there yet.
I never did.
I told him I never did.
And she told me, she said,
you know that man was sitting right next to you.
See, that's the manager of Butler's shoe store.
And I couldn't wrap Butler's shoes because I,
I was then a skin and many of you might say.
And the mayor of feet, you know.
And they didn't have nothing to fit me.
So I went on in there.
And he asked me, I'm happy.
Then they would get down and marry you.
You didn't go and buy shoes without.
And I said, I don't think he's here.
I said, it's a little wide.
He wouldn't got another pair.
I said,
aren't you the man that I said next to it, I'll drugs him.
He said, yes, I ain't.
I said, I was just thinking.
You couldn't sit on a stool next to me and eat,
but you can sit between my legs and major muscle.
And got up and walked out.
I said, I was going to get $0.10.
He was gone.
You saw me.
I just got up and walked out.
And I went in there by myself.
Did you plan that?
You just said, I'm going to go do it.
Did they start to look out for you so you come in?
No, that's the only one I went to.
I always said, and I knew my son would never do it.
I said, if we ever be in world where it's a crisis of
one of those stores that sell your lunch, you know.
People would spank their kids if they got up on the stool.
That made them feel good.
I mean the waitresses of the knock.
I said, my daughter decides she wants something of that.
And she gets on that stool and we'll get up there next to her.
But I know my son would never have done it.
He wouldn't have tried it.
She said, Mama, the only reason I didn't sit up there,
did nothing look tempting, but I wanted it.
She told me that about three or four weeks ago.
She said, I saw them people like this account.
She said, but, when nothing there,
I thought I wanted it.
Didn't you tell me at the beginning of the interview
that you were a shy person?
I've always been shy.
But they've moved me out of there.
It really?
How did it do that?
And then I never talked.
When I did my first...
Put your cup.
In a view, what they call them?
The old history.
It was 9-1-1.
September 9th, 11.
And Dr. Convey of Dieting.
I talked two hours.
I told it, man, I never talked that long.
So every 9-1-1, we always call.
You call me, and I call you.
We didn't know that 9-1-1 was going on to begin.
In doing the interview, and don't know what happened.
And it's 9-1-1.
You call me when she's stating that interview for you.
So how did the movement get you over your shyness?
I don't know.
I don't...
And I always be secretive.
I need it.
One time, my beautician club, they thought they'd change up
a lot.
It would have been a long time.
They'd eat me president.
They were glad to get rid of me.
I'm a secretary.
I couldn't do all that.
They'd talk to me.
I don't know what happened.
So would you go around and talk to...
Well, you said before you talked to your customers about the poll,
you talked to them about registering during the movement.
They were kind of on their own about that time.
They were going.
They don't say that.
So you'd already kind of worked on it.
Did you canvas, did you go around asking people to register?
Oh, yeah.
Some people would say, I'm not interested.
And then some wanted to, but they...
But when the students got there, it was a different thing.
They got them out.
You know how?
Talking to them out of the gifts, I don't know.
But...
When we registered for the party, we had better than 3000.
Oh.
Of course, with the party they didn't have to go to the courthouse.
Yeah, that's right, go.
We'd go to the house.
And when we got to Atlantic City,
the country people would have come to town.
Lot of us had been out of the state of Mississippi.
And we had to make to pictures.
It rolled us in our hair.
What was the trip to Atlantic City like?
Were you on the bus?
On the bus.
It was three buses.
Because we took all our papers and everything, you know.
When we was organizing our party, you know.
We thought we were going to be the ones.
We really did.
But, remember, Lyndon Johnson, he...
He stopped being a loop.
What did you think of the compromising to see?
There wasn't no way.
No way.
But, you know, to tell the truth, the men in the group wanted it.
It was the women that saved us.
Why did the men want it?
They say we're listening to Adam Clayton Powell Jr Jr
and all the other big officers and whatever, you know.
And they say that politics is like...
You give and you take.
And that was...
We spoke to give it.
And what about the women?
You know, Fannie Lou Hamer.
I didn't come all this way from Mississippi.
From the two non-cam votes.
I mean, it's going to give you two seats and you couldn't vote.
You know, we wouldn't have it.
Why do you think the men and women looked at it differently?
I don't know.
I mean, they didn't.
They did.
I guess men...
The man was telling them that you should take it.
And the whites, they left and went home.
They didn't even state it.
The regular party?
Yes.
So, Mississippi seats were empty.
You all went on the floor?
Yes.
We didn't sit in those seats.
Some delegates from other states gave us their cadenters.
And that's how we got in.
Did you have any trouble on the floor?
Did people try to get you out?
No, no, no, no.
Did you work with Mrs. Gray?
Yes.
She was okay with me.
I was like her.
She drove, and I just...
I would go with her a lot of places.
Been all over the state.
Just me and her.
In her car.
And I don't know.
I'm kind of concerned.
Because she got married in her school,
in service, and so she got temps to go to see you and all.
But every time she would come to Hattiesburg,
she would come by and see me.
I go with her somewhere.
We went to WDAN one night after 10 o'clock.
And she was being interviewed.
But when they started organizing in Jackson,
she never asked me to come.
She never asked.
She would always come back.
She said, oh, we have a good time.
The young people really interested in it.
And she was just telling me and...
didn't about it, and know nothing about me until...
her room had sent those pictures.
But I...
And then they started circling.
And they'd say it was people in that delegation.
Don't even remember me.
Because I was quiet.
When she was talking about in Jackson and organizing...
What was that?
That's when they started organizing the...
They had an anniversary.
Five years, they started one year to...
And then they got...
So you sort of got left out of the history for a while.
So the pictures are spent about what?
15, 20 years?
Yeah, it's been just about that long.
You were one of the key people in the MFDP...
At the beginning.
And see, I can remember...
I went to Mount Buebliffe or something...
And come back by the Copa office.
And when I went in the Copa office,
a lady told me, she said, we got some papers for you to say.
And I heard somebody say, I didn't look around or nothing.
And they said, no, she didn't do that anymore.
But I didn't question it.
Because I wasn't going to do nothing to hurt the movement.
But...
You know what that was?
Well...
You didn't even say that you didn't do that anymore.
Because they had put Mrs. Annie Devine as the secretary of the party.
It couldn't say she was exeggity.
But she's secretary of the party.
And I know they didn't hold no meat to do that.
I think I was too young for those other two women.
And they wanted...
And I never asked her nothing about it.
I never asked, guillot, I never...
I walked out of the Copa office that day.
And I haven't been back since.
They've been trying to get me come up there.
The Copa building?
The Copa building.
And so...
Do you remember when that was?
Was that like 65 or 66?
It must have been...
Was it after the challenge?
Oh, oh yes.
After the congressional challenge?
When the same challenge the representatives?
Yeah, it was after that.
And we all went to Washington.
I went with them.
Were you in that group?
That's right.
I was in that group.
So tell us about that.
Some of them were wave-action, some speak, and some didn't want to know you.
So this is when Congress is getting ready to start.
And that's when Annie Devine and Miss Hamer and Miss Adams got on the floor.
I would say.
And so all of the Congress people that were walked through the hallway from building to the next?
That's from the representatives to the big building.
I think it was to where their offices are, to where they meet.
Oh, and it was so pretty down at to me.
Right, right, right.
But they saw some beautiful people.
Did you remember Michael Thelwell?
He was in SNCC.
And he was mostly in Washington.
He worked on that.
And so he was telling me about when you were in the hallway.
He said he thought that made the difference on some people's vote.
That's what it was supposed to do.
Yeah, well he thinks it worked.
So would you go to regular meetings for the statewide cofo and MFDP?
Would they have state meetings?
Oh yeah.
Actually, we haven't talked about so.
How did you get elected a delegate for the MFTP to go to Atlantic City?
You know, I don't know how I got elected.
Well, I was the first one.
It was a heated thing going on in that meeting.
People were all excited.
They had act up with the Alabama and the police had beat up a lot of people.
And we were just...
And they had a petition or something that we signed.
I went up and I was the first one to sign the petition.
And somebody nominated me to...
to head to the party.
But those people didn't know me.
So I just...
I don't know what...
I think God had a lot to do here.
I just put me in here.
But they voted for me.
Who else went from Hattiesburg to Jacksonville?
You see George Harper, Pinky.
No, their names are not in there.
But see if I can...
Yeah, Henry Ahring.
And this is Schwerner.
What's his name?
Rita?
Yeah.
Stepto, George Harper.
Oh, it was...
You told that from Hattiesburg.
I'm trying to think.
It's people who had...
John and me Walker.
It was about...
about 15 or 20, I can't think about all of it right now.
It's so strong, I can't believe it.
Can you tell me about some of the SNCC people that you remember that stand out for you?
They were.
Can you tell me about some of the SNCC people that you remember?
People that stand out?
Oh, Prathia Hall.
And we can't get him to butch, no kind of way now.
But Prathia Hall.
Oh, what's it?
Prathia Hall.
I can't thank God.
But it was quite a few.
It's a little Ella Baker spoke in Hattiesburg at Mass meetings.
Yeah.
Do you remember her speaking?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, she's another thing in her Lou.
Have a lover.
She got a little bit of air to her but...
some strong women.
Did you ever talk to her?
I might have talked with her twice maybe.
No, I didn't.
Back then I didn't know about it at all.
What about Miss Hamer?
Miss Hamer.
Oh, yeah.
I have a lot of talks with her.
She's real.
And I didn't know when she died because my dad was sick at that time.
I didn't, in 77, I think.
I didn't know she was that sick.
And when Miss Adams died, I didn't realize she was that sick.
You know, good.
They brought her back here.
She most funeralized that Parkway Hikes over here.
Yeah, it's not far from 49.
Did you know Mr. Damon?
Yes, I knew Mr. Damon.
Yeah.
Uh, Mr. Damon.
I don't know where all the sadists are not.
I don't know how Miss Damon would think about it.
But you know the NAACP.
They had put him out to get you.
You had heard that.
Maybe she had talked about it.
I haven't never asked her about it.
I saw the letter that they wrote in.
We were in the ministerial allowances side of the building where they minister's stating
that Bunk Beats and Mr. Farrell had his radio and Mr. Jackson on the side.
I was sitting on one of the little parts of it.
And when he died, they come in to a call.
They sort of get...
But I was told that they promised to build that house back up here.
There were boys and they stood up to get that house back.
What was the reason that the National K's put them out?
They did not want him working with snakes.
You know, he had SNCC people in his house before it...
Miss Woods opened up a place for him.
He was just warm to help and he was glad to get it.
Did many people know about what was the National and how it was making cocoa?
I don't think too many people knew.
What was it like when they found this house?
I could not believe it.
We went out there and Taylor and she was one that went to the convention in New Jersey.
But we went out there early that morning.
Still smoking.
It was still smoking all night.
I just could not believe.
Just call them all God, that's what it was.
I went to see him in the hospital and I said to the day,
the man was dying.
I guess he just...
And they moved this door in the bedroom with a lady.
But they said he died from smoke and he was talking when I left.
I guess I might have been home about 30 minutes when I...
Woolett was a dad.
I just did believe they gave him smoke.
He was talking.
Who was he saying?
Just talking about how he was trying to get out the house and all that.
Did that make you afraid?
No, not then.
I don't know.
I believe me having my dad in there, my dad.
Did you have weapons in the house?
We had a shotgun.
And dad had a 38.
But we ate locked up.
Was your neighborhood safer?
Yeah.
Did white people they didn't come in your neighborhood?
Mobile street is a busy street.
And that's all busy night.
It's busy.
The man is a carpenter.
He was working on one of the houses.
That three houses up from that house.
He said, oh man came down with a beautician lia and said he told him.
I don't know about it then.
I'm just doing some carton of work here this afternoon.
He came straight home and told me that he was trying to find out where I live.
So my understanding is that some of the white town town wanted to try to help with the house.
Did you build their house?
To my day in the house?
Yeah.
He was a professor at the college, William Carey College.
And some of me was supposed to be getting him.
But he didn't come up like it's supposed to have.
He did do what he could, I guess.
What made him do that?
Why did he?
I don't know.
But all along when the movement first got started, it was some white street would call and ask them to send somebody out to wherever.
It wouldn't be a bad house, they're home and they would meet them and they would give them money.
It's always been somebody in the white community that could treat.
Did you ever have a sense of who those people were?
No.
If anybody can get an older history from Dovesmith, he won't give.
He stayed in something starting.
Carabiner, Tennessee, it's the Upper Memphis.
Something started with a C.
Carabiner.
They sent him, they called him and sent him to Vietnam.
Was he from the community?
Oh yeah, born here.
And joined the movement and got drafted.
Did you work with the Frames schools?
No, I didn't work with the Freedom School because I was trying to make some money at that time.
So when your business had dried up?
Did that upset you to lose all that business?
No, it didn't.
Because I've been fool with hair since I was 11 years old and his staff were meeting me.
What about head start?
I didn't work part with head start.
And that might be the reason that they changed from executive.
I've been trying to find, forget to think for me, because we talked, it was Child Development Group of Mississippi.
Child Development Group of Mississippi?
Yeah, Child Development Group of Mississippi.
And the delegates, when we went to Washington, and we got a chance to talk with Sargent Shriver.
And he told us about it.
And we would get the first one in the United States.
And it was another one going to follow ours.
And to see how it come, because Mississippi had turned it down.
It didn't want to.
And then after we got it going and doing, they took it away from us with the help of some of our other people.
So I don't know how you feel about talking about that, but I was wondering about what is that.
And then also the difference between the delegation and the 64 and the delegation in 68.
They went to Chicago.
You want to talk about what happened between the two?
I don't know.
I wasn't even going there.
I was just, no, because he had started.
It was early on that.
It was, I think, 65.
Yeah.
And I believe I got a job.
A system community worker.
That's what it was.
And this grade had a friend, Helen Anderson.
And she had already made a reign that she would be.
And she was just the community.
And I told myself, I take anything because I need some money.
But anyway, I did.
But all that.
You can work for a head start.
You had to be.
They didn't want you to do political work.
That's right.
So you think you suspect maybe that's why you got moved out of that.
But somebody would have talked to me.
Did that hurt you?
It did.
When they, somebody, I didn't even look around.
They said, no, she don't do that number.
And I didn't add to no questions.
And that's still happening.
Is there anybody around for those things?
To ask.
I think I'm back only when I'm still living of the delegates.
I think.
Dr. McLemore?
Oh, Dr. Macklemo and you need her.
Is she still living?
As far as I know.
You need her.
And King.
King.
Yeah.
Mongo.
How did your name come to be on the leave on that lawsuit, kind of versus Johnson?
Because I was an executive secretary on the party.
What was the case about?
And you know, I didn't know until then they say, you know, some people think if you president,
you can part of, but it's the record keeper.
And that's who the government go after.
Did they go after you?
No, I didn't.
I didn't do nothing for them.
And you can bleed with sand around.
You're going to keep good financial records.
What was he like?
Like some sergeant in his suit.
He was a drill sergeant?
Yeah, he was very good.
Did you like him?
I liked him.
Yeah.
You told me before that he took you down to the bank?
Yes, I had never opened a account.
He took me down there.
So even though you had a business, you had never had an account at the bank.
It was just a cash and cash.
And that was your first checking account.
That's very true.
Did he stay for a while?
He stayed a little while long.
Maybe not quite a year.
You know, it's snowing, it's starting to fall.
But with each other and all.
So...
Was it hard when they left?
No, it was not like...
A good friend, like...
A lost good friend.
He never got in touch with us either.
Is he related?
Oh, he's dead.
When we had our 30th anniversary, I think it was 30th.
It's seven.
He came and he didn't know nobody.
He and his son...
The people one of them took care of him.
Well, I think somebody could he have an accident to the vet in three ways?
Well, somebody beat him up.
Real bad in New York.
I think Sheila found it myself, didn't he?
She was Michael?
She worked with him.
Yes, she was...
I'd say a deer, honey.
Yes, she was good.
Dog cheek.
She took care of that office.
You can call and ask about anybody that was down here.
She knew where he was singing.
You said you had people at your house?
Sheila did.
She stayed with a friend of mine, Miss Wallace, on Seventh Street.
Did you say that you had the first flight?
Yes, and I can't think of a last name.
Mary something.
It wasn't Mary Kim, but she wasn't in High School.
She was talking to me, snog with a beer, something like that.
She was little, little.
But like me, I was little, then.
I had was down to a waist.
So, what would you want people to know about the movie?
The open door was here.
Nobody thought they were better than anybody.
You know, you're just...
I'm the longest.
I'm trying to put the cursor in somebody.
You know what?
You can know what I put it on.
And who would have bored meetings?
We at Rev. R.L.T. Smith's house, I can't think of his other name.
In town?
Rev. R.L.T. Smith and Haddishburg?
No, it was in Jackson.
In Jackson.
Rev. R.L.T. Smith?
Rev. R.L.T. Smith.
That's why we would have a lot of bored meetings in his house.
MFDP, Ford or Cofo?
MFDP.
We were all sitting in chairs and they were sitting on the floor in Cacket Pants.
It's Nick.
It's Nick's students.
No, the lawyers, honey.
The lawyers were...
Sitting down like they were.
And we sit down.
You're New York lawyers, right?
Yes, I said, hmm.
Cofs, you know, down here.
Well, they were in suits.
They didn't kind of carry you on that.
What did you think of?
Small.
If they told you something, that was it.
That was going to happen.
What happened with...
Have we talked about what the counter case was?
What that case was about?
Connor v. Johnson?
It was about getting some very elected people in offices.
It was two suits in people don't mean.
One, I said, two.
One for local and one for the state.
And I think they kind of put them together, but that's where we got a lot of black,
elected officials in Jackson.
Did it change the district lines?
Yeah, they had to.
That was it.
That was what the soup was about.
So that's how we got a Congressman of Black Congressman from the Society.
Yeah, that's because.
And that particular district is fixed where it's going to be.
Or you take a miracle.
That's what it was about.
And that's all the one.
That's all the one.
And Percy Watson,
Perts of Watson, I voted for him every time he rang.
And he hadn't recognized who I was until about four years ago.
And still.
What happened when he recognized you?
He made out of a parking machine or something and presented it in Jackson.
I got a copy.
It's in a frame.
Were you there for it?
No, I didn't know I'm about to them too.
He invited me.
He had a Christmas party every year.
And it's the first year I got an invitation to the Christmas party.
So what do you think about that?
The proclamation?
Did it make you happy?
Yeah.
What did you think about it?
I didn't think too much of it.
And I can see him now.
He might pass right now.
He goes there, we'll say.
So he did the proclamation.
Well, I found a lot of these electric fishes.
I don't want to be associated with me, period.
Why not?
They don't.
I don't know.
They know what kind of...
They get that office and all and they just...
They forget how they got there.
Yes, mm-hmm.
So what do you think are the biggest successes of the movement?
Well, I think these black elected officials
doesn't make a difference in people's lives?
You know, it's just the number that got you know.
They don't have a stone list.
Have them that live in Jackson.
They all attend the meetings and things, you know.
They just be there when they can and when they live.
I was going to ask whether you disappointments, whether the things that you hope to be better than they are.
Well,
it's not too much I can say about that because the main thing we need,
we don't have and they love each other.
You know, it's as long as we keep bickering and fagging.
We are never getting better.
Are you hopeful?
Oh, I'm not going to get up on that love yet.
So are there things that I should ask you about that I haven't?
I can't think of anything.
I don't know if it's a special injection.
When I was arrested in Jackson I was put on the third floor up there
but away from the majority of the people.
What was the protest about?
Oh, and one funny thing.
I was doing that demonstration, you know.
Charles Evers was just there just to see.
And he was running out of his jet.
He was, he was demonstrating.
That took a few.
He came in the head of Spurig after Mr. Damon was murdered.
He was a national.
So why did they put you on the third floor?
I don't know.
I was up there.
They tried to make sure he didn't organize everybody else.
I don't know.
And Monica went to Monica.
He got away with the jail thing too.
We had to pay money to get out of it but we got it back.
Some people, some of her people sent money to my daddy.
And my daddy got both of us up the same day.
So was she working in Harrisburg?
She came here when she first came to the state.
She worked in Hattiesburg,
And then she moved to Jackson.
So did she come in freedom somewhere?
Yeah.
And she stayed at my house.
Oh, did she?
I didn't know that.
She said daddy was like a daddy to her.
Yeah.
And he was on the codes.
And they ended up there.
Washington.
No, in Jackson?
Oh, and then eventually Washington.
So they were both working in Jackson.
What was that protest about in Jackson?
Or you got arrested?
It was something about trying to date.
We were.
They were in session.
And they just made you get their homes in session.
And it's something that they were playing on, voting on,
stop demonstrations in Jackson.
And we went to the capital.
We didn't get a chance to do no kind of ticket to him or nothing.
We had our little things, you know.
But out of the car, I got into Pateaway.
That's right.
Didn't you?
So they did.
Whatever it was, I don't think they ever passed it.
It was a special session called for that.
And I sing the thing and a lot of us sing the thing.
Read nothing was done too much.
He had his bird because the governor was from Hattiesburg. (Paul Burney) Johnson Jr.
Call the Johnson.
And I was in Hattiesburg.
And so that kind of kept it down.
Because most of the people here in Hattiesburg,
they didn't want the news to get out.
Something happened in Hattiesburg.
So they tried to keep things under control?
Yeah. And that's the same way when we integrated schools.
They wouldn't go hand on demonstrations in front of the schools.
You know, like parents and everybody else come out and nobody come to school with the children.
So they tried to keep the white leadership, tried to keep the world's town,
keep out of the news.
And you think it's because it was Johnson's hometown?
And he lived.
Yeah, I don't believe that.
So here we are at Southern,
which was segregated until the 60s.
Has it changed?
Yes. We have, I was told,
we have more black students on this campus than any other.
I was told school in the state that include the blacks and the whites.
It's a big school, isn't it?
It's a big campus here.
And it's got a lot of most of people up there.
Is it? I knew it had changed a lot.
So does that make you happy about that?
Well, yes.
I'm alright with it.
It's nice to have a college here that you can actually go to.
Can you think of anything else?
I can't think of anything.
It's been a very good interview.
Thank you.
We appreciate you not supporting us.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.